head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smoky Mike in the god king
that's Jeremy boring and Michael nolles
and with your help we will smash our way
onto the Billboard charts here's the big
news ladies and gentlemen from cnr.com
Colorado Supreme Court has disqualified
president Trump from GOP Primary ballot
now of course it's more than just this
if they're arguing Trump is to be
removed from the primary bout they're
also saying the general as well scr
uh.com reports the Colorado Supreme
Court disqualified Trump from appearing
on the 2024 GOP Presidential primary
ballot Tuesday's decision comes after a
lower court judge in Denver ruled
against removing his ballot access quote
a majority of the Court holds that
President Trump is disqualified from
holding the office of president under
section three of the 14th Amendment of
the United States of the United States
Constitution because he is disqualified
it would be a wrongful act under the
election codee for the Colorado
Secretary of State to list him as a
candidate on the presidential primary
ballot now many experts have argued this
is a gross
misinterpretation the 14th Amendment
does not bar someone from running for
president it it's only related to
Federal officers which are individuals
appointed by the president or
representatives and Senators not the
president
himself the lawsuit has cited a
never-before used Civil War air
provision of the 14th am which we all
know crew has argued Trump summoned tens
of thousands of enraged supporters for a
wild protest in DC and that racism and
white supremacy the same violent
ideologies that led to Civil War in its
wake the 14th Amendment pervaded Trump's
Insurrection and movement surrounding it
there's there there's similar lawsuits
being filed uh all across the country
several states have already ruled no we
uh uh judges we may see these get
appealed to the Supreme Court and the
same thing may happen you know I thought
it was going to be Colorado now there is
some important there's an important
distinction here the Colorado Supreme
Court ruling is stayed until January 4th
but that's
meaningless all this means
is by by saying Trump can't appear on
the ballot they're saying when it comes
time to print the ballot don't include
Trump's Name by claiming the ruling is
state is meaningless because they're not
printing the ballots right now the
question is if three months out from
Super Tuesday Colorado Donald they do
not resolve this Trump will not appear
and then guess who's going to win the
primary I'd imagine Ronda Sanz this is
going this has oh man you guys ready I
hope you have a trusty fifth by your
side because for those that are enjoying
a nice drinking game you're going to
need it but uh we'll start slow we'll
start slow I know you're all getting
ready but not yet first the GOP is going
to erupt into uh uh just bickering and
infighting like we've already seen I
mean one of the big stories out of last
night with Tucker was that Tucker
Carlson said the people who repres to S
on line is some of the nastiest
stupidest and zero some people he's ever
seen it is apparent that uh the
Republican party is is not getting along
however most people support Donald Trump
and I'm not saying Republicans most
people when they remove him from the
primary and they and the RNC tries to
give the nomination to someone else I
mean this there's going to be a Revolt
yeah there there was a lot of people
that took issue with what Tucker said
about uh the dant campaign and I've seen
some of it like the there are some
people on the the Des campaign that have
been fairly nasty and stuff but there
were a lot of people that were really
upset that Tucker had the audacity to
you know point that point to to say that
he saw that or that that was they all
from the disantis campaign I think they
were well that's it's a lot of fans of
disantis but look when Christina Pasha
who is basically Ronda sanz's number two
is personally leading flame Wars against
Trump's fans yeah you've debased
yourself you have lowered yourself to
that of a fan so if like Taylor Swift
and Rihanna's fans are like arguing on
Twitter neither Swift nor Rihanna get
involved and nor do they care and that's
basically what Ronda santz campaign has
decided to be just on on par with
Trump's fan base instead of trump
himself so be it so be it but removing
Trump from the ballot is the only way
these people could win which it's no
surprise they've all made the move to
try and win the nomination because they
all expect at least everyone except for
V they expect Trump to be removed this
would be a great opportunity for them to
prove everybody wrong and recognize the
moment that we're living in and for them
to say this is much bigger than my
political campaign this is much bigger
than the Republican nomination Vivic let
it off perfectly if they all rally
around right now rally around Donald
Trump and say hey this is actually about
preserving our Democratic Republic
that's what I think it's going to take
for us to actually win because if we're
divided I mean I I fought a really hard
Republican primary last year uh and
unfortunately came up short because the
Democrats don't play that game if we
fall for this this time and we are not
unified we're not just going to lose the
presidency I I'm afraid we'd lose the
entire country so I hope everyone
recognizes what time it is right now and
gets really serious they don't it's the
uh try to be optimistic you know what we
should do you know you know the the the
Minutes to Midnight clock the Doomsday
Clock they have we should get one of
those we call the minutes of civil war
ah there it is and will inch It Forward
I I love this I'm seeing a bunch of
Democrats tweeting in celebration yeah
and I'm just responding being like I'm
really glad they did this because
democracy is very dangerous to our
democracy right democracy dies during
the Democratic process right yeah the
number of people on the the what you
would assume to be the
responsible reasonable left that uh are
going to jump on this and be like oh
well you know and make
excuses there has been no due process to
remove Trump from the primaries I'm not
sure what
mechanism uh Colorado has is is using
I'm not sure what they're they like
redefined the law right they defin it as
it can be for for a president that was
what they voted on I guess well yeah I I
mean I I suppose but there's no other
like it's unprecedented for someone to
be you know he's he hasn't been charged
with Insurrection Insurrection is a
specific thing and it something that's
outlawed I mean outlined in the law like
there are certain criteria that have to
be met he hasn't met them to actually
have have carried to be to there there's
there's legis the legislative branch has
codified what Insurrection would be
there's an Insurrection act yeah this is
this is but but let's address this
because everyone keeps saying the same
thing and I don't think there's a
definitive answer just yet but we have
this Trump campaign blasts Colorado
Colorado judges who are moved from 2024
ballot vows to appeal to the US Supreme
Court as he should and he has to and a
lot of people are saying but you know
that they do this and Trump will
immediately go to scotus and get it
overturned perhaps but also understand I
don't know if the Supreme Court may be
favorable to Trump perhaps I don't know
that the Supreme Court actually can
overturn this ruling yeah I'm I'm sure
you're going to get a bunch of people
screaming the ninth and 10th Amendment
this is not a general election held
under us constitutional rules this is a
private primary nomination process held
by a state in tandem with other states
to determine at a National Convention
who a private organization will choose
to be their nominee not a general the
Supreme Court may very well take up the
case and they may say we have no
jurisdiction over what a state
organization is doing as it pertains to
a private organization's nomination
process
imagine if someone was running to be the
captain of the bridge club and there was
some Tom Foolery about and the bouts
were you know screwed up and then
someone I'm going to I'm going to go to
the Supreme Court over this they'd be
like we don't care about your private
organization's leadership structure
right mhm I don't know the Supreme Court
can intervene in a primary yeah and even
if it was Federal that the Precedence
isn't really great I mean the Texas case
where Texas attempted to sue all the
states where there was discrepancies in
the election that never even got into
the Supreme Court so I mean this is just
law fair even if Trump can get it into
the Supreme Court they're just bleeding
him out they're making him expend
resources that no other candidates
having to expend and they're also
beating it more into people's heads
Insurrection Insurrection 14th Amendment
and then those of us that are you know
in the news every day will say no but
actually he's never been charged he's
never been convicted but all people are
going to hear who are suable is they're
going to hear oh Insurrection man he
must have been guilty of an Insurrection
but look the worrying thing and the
reason why everyone should uh um get
ready with their fifth uh uh maybe maybe
they have Jack or something is
because when you have what is Trump
polling at 2.3 up in aggregate across
the country you can say Trump is an
insurrectionist but the average person
is not accepting that no matter how many
times they scream it the average person
in this country the majority not even
the plurality support Donald Trump so
you run the risk of ripping this country
in half now I'll give you some
predictions Colorado removes Donald
Trump from the primary several other
states follow and they even make
reference to Colorado and other states
Trump gets removed from the primaries
they don't need to worry about the
general election yep Ronda sandis and
Nikki Haley end up neck and neck Ronda
santis wins you now have what a 2024
four-way
race probably not Biden maybe let's say
Biden RFK Jr Trump and disantis all
running so so perhaps what would happen
then
is no one gets 270 electoral votes it
goes to house delegations it goes to
Donald Trump let's say
that Donald Trump is removed from the
ballot in Colorado but but still ends up
winning the
nomination that's I think Colorado has
as of 2020 like 1.6 1.7 million
Republican
voters what will end up happening is if
new numerous states that are blue we
don't expect Trump to win anyway remove
him from the ballot Trump will win the
electoral college with 50 60 million
votes and Joe Biden will have 75 or
whoever or Newsome Trump will win the
electoral college becoming president the
media will then say the Electoral
College is archaic and broken how can we
have a president when he had 20 million
less votes the average person who
doesn't pay attention has no idea why
that is they will simply be told told
people didn't vote for Trump when the
reality is you couldn't if you wanted to
then what happens to the sentiment in
this country the people who support
Trump Won't Back Down the people in
Colorado who support him and want to
vote for him but who can't will still
keep supporting him this how I think we
inch towards uh Civil War that's why
it's so dangerous I mean if you love
this country and you want this country
to remain as it is and continue on our
path towards progress like having the
judicial branch step in and say no we're
going to decide who's on the ballot it's
incredibly dangerous and I I think the
Democrats just don't care they're
willing to burn down the entire system
right now just to stop Trump from coming
back they're ready for it to go to the
Supreme Court like I can already hear
them screeching about Clarence Thomas
and his wife like if it goes there like
they've got that ready to go you know so
that's like an invisible landmine that
they just they plant all these waiting
for it to go that way what happens when
without
legislation come August or uh July of
I don't know inserts insert State
Arizona just says look we've gone over
it we think Colorado was right Secretary
of State just says we will not be
including Donald Trump on the ballot for
the general election based on what we've
seen across this country the rulings are
clear blah blah blah sue us and then
they print the ballots without Trump
yeah every single activist uh you know
Justice right now at the at the state
level every single activist judge
they're licking their chops right now
they want to be the next ones to do this
M and this is just blazing the path
Arizona loves doing it yeah Arizon west
coast states let me just say um I fully
expect every single Trump supporter to
not only agree with what I just said but
actually take it a step further they you
you should be thinking I'm wrong because
I'm not going far enough as to what the
Democrats are going to do if you truly
believe that 2020 was stolen from Trump
in The Most Extreme Ways with you know
you know Ian talks about flipping votes
even that can be done through hacking
voting machines and fraudulent ballots
then you better damn well believe
that a secretary of state banging a
gavel figuratively is the first thing
they do if you think fraud is on the
menu the first thing they do is just
erase Trump's name and say sue us and
while you're suing them they'll be doing
who knows what yeah getting ready for
phase two I mean look how tight the
margins were in the in the key swing
states where Trump maybe lost 2020 I
mean we're talking about 12,000 votes
10,000 votes in just a couple places so
all it takes is a few secretary States
or even County Auditors just to whoopsy
and not have Trump on the ballot they
can say look we confused like he's an
insurrectionist right 14th Amendment and
then there you go yeah we thought
everyone agreed I mean I don't know what
do what were you doing media said it
over and over again yeah exactly I was
listening to like CBS ABC all those
types of places on the way in and they
just they use Insurrection with a
certain tone there's no no Nuance to it
whatsoever they're in another dimension
completely and and the people who listen
to them unless it's like someone
listening to them to see what their
point of view is which I'm sure there's
some like me and other others of us they
buy into that that dimension
oh go it no good no no this is
fascinating we'll get into it in a
little bit but you know Donald Trump
recently had this quote where he was
referring to Democrats poisoning the
blood of this country through their bad
policies principally immigration and you
get all of the media screaming Trump is
now like Hitler because Hitler wrote in
minec blood poison and things like that
the funny thing is the people being
pulled in urban Democrat strongholds
overwhelmingly agree with Donald Trump
yeah they're they're they're outraged
over the migrant problem now again I
we'll save the migrant stuff because we
do have a bigger subject on that but I
just want to point out the media is
acting like the American people don't
matter at all right it's almost as if
the corporate press realized you know
what we no longer convince people let's
just keep saying the same thing knowing
they don't believe us and who cares the
Deep state will come in with the with
the boot and the Iron Fist and we'll do
what we want anyway thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a member
over at timcast.net